well the squad has spoken ladies and
gentlemen the squad has spoken the squad
is endorsing Bernie Sanders for
president well 3/4 of the squad is
anyway
Talib Omar AOC there and then the other
one what's her name Ringo is not she's I
don't know what she's doing but I
unfortunately you know you feel bad for
her nobody cares who she endorses they
only care about the three main ones and
this is really fascinating
these young young women of color
politicians who live and breathe
identity politics it is it is their
lifeblood it is coursing through their
veins identity politics and so they're
looking at the the field of Democratic
candidates trying to decide who to
endorse and they decide to endorse a six
hundred and fifty year old white guy for
president it just it's it's they're
endorsing an ancient wealthy white male
career politician meanwhile meanwhile
there's a perfectly good ancient wealthy
white female career politician who they
could endorse they're also a few
non-whites candidates that you go but no
it's got to be it's got to be the old
white guy people will offer their own
explanations for why they're doing this
you know why why Sanders and not Warren
Warren would seem like the obvious
choice for them but I think here's my
just just my gut instinct I think this
is sort of a Mean Girls situation this
is a Mean Girls jealousy thing where you
know one of them wants to be the first
female president and so they just don't
want Warren to steal their thunder I
think that's what this is about they
don't want they don't want to have they
don't like her because basically they
don't like her because she's a woman and
she's taking she's gonna take all the
the attention away from them so um as
for the debate last night as you know I
take my job as a podcast host very
seriously because it's a very serious
and important job so you know it's one
of those things it's such an important
job it's one of those things where if
there was some sort of apocalyptic
asteroid strike
and we were you know and and before the
asteroid comes we've got a bunker and we
can only put a few people in the bunker
to rebuild human civilization after
after the the asteroid strike whenever
when everyone else is killed and we're
deciding who's gonna put the bunker you
know well of course you need a you need
a doctor in the bunker you need you know
you maybe you need you need a couple
scientists you need people who can hunt
you need a carpenter but you're also
gonna need a podcast host it because
who's gonna be hosting the podcast as we
worry about rebuild civilization anyway
the point is very important job so even
though I'd rather shove a rusty butter
knife directly into my eyeballs and then
watch another 3-hour democratic debate I
did you know I I did choose last night
the debate over the rusty butter knife
because I needed to provide you with the
searing insightful political analysis
that you definitely have not come to
expect for me but I have to admit I just
I couldn't do it I just I couldn't make
it all the way through I tried
dear God did I try it was just so boring
I am so bored by this so about two hours
in I ended up muting it and watching
youtube videos but I did see I still had
it on I just wasn't really paying
attention to it I did look up and I see
how they spent the final half-hour of
the debate talking about their favorite
friendships not a joke if you watch it
I'm not kidding they spent the last half
hour half hour about of the debate
talking about their friendships the last
question which again they spent about
thirty minutes on was about their most I
think it was their Moto's that their
most surprising friendships and they
each went they each is a very important
question they each had a chance to
answer and they went through one by one
talking about their friendships that
would have been I think a really great
question
if these people were running for
treasurer of student council in fifth
grade but I'm pretty sure they're
running just this
appearances they are running for
president of the United States of
America so I'm not sure we really care
about their friendships what's next I
mean maybe the next debate they'll spend
the last last part of it that you know
the CNN will ask a candidates what is
cuter a panda or a seal you'll each have
20 minutes to respond go ahead
as for the other notable moments I guess
there were of the parts of the debate
that I watched there were a few things
maybe sort of worth talking about and
we'll get to that in a second but first
a word from Boland branch
speaking of debates here's something
that we don't need to debate we could
all agree on this sleep is good and
second we could all use more of it
thankfully getting a great night's sleep
is easier than ever thanks to the
world's softest sheets brought to you by
Boland branch everything bullet branch
makes from bedding to blankets is made
from pure 100% organic cotton it's just
it's the best material that you can have
for for for bedding and blankets and
sheets and everything which means they
start out really soft they only get
softer over time everyone who tries
bullet branch sheets loves them that's
why they have thousands of five-star
reviews don't take it for me and go and
look at the reviews yourself people love
these things and in Balham branch wants
you to love your purchase too so they
offer a no risk 30-day trial and free
shipping but you know you're not gonna
want to send them back you have that
this just shows the confidence that
Boleyn branch has in their product
because once you sleep on their sheets
you'll never want to sleep on anything
else again to get you started right now
my listeners get $50 off your first set
of sheets at Boleyn branch calm promo
code matt go to bowl and branch calm for
to get 50% of $50 off your first set of
sheets
that's bol l and branch calm promo code
Matt Boleyn branch calm promo code met
okay before we get back to the debate I
think the more important thing going on
today is the website pink news which is
an LGBT website they've apparently been
given the distinct honor of naming the
gender-neutral penguin in the London Zoo
which is a which is a thing and that's a
real thing
there's a gender-neutral penguin
and so I guess the zoo said to pink news
you guys can name the penguin and so
they put a poll up on Twitter with four
options and if you want to go you go to
Twitter if you want to vote in this very
important thing but the options are
rockso cheddar ziggy pumpkin now what do
you think about that remember this is a
this is a gender-neutral penguin it's
actually as I understand it is a it is a
gender-neutral pansexual vegan communist
penguin easily the whoa kissed aquatic
bird of all time but here's my question
do any of those names live up to the
woke nosov this penguin cheddar sounds
like the nickname you give to the
fattest guy in the biker gang
rockso is the name of a mob hit man
Ziggy doesn't really work and pumpkin is
a nickname that fathers sometimes give
to their daughters which is highly
offensive and traumatic and it puts
young girls in a gendered box where they
now have the expectation that they're
gonna grow up to become you know a large
squash so here's my idea
Skyy Aspen Addison Oswin I don't even
know if that's a name it just sounds
like Keegan Dakota Zane
Shiloh any of those names are better or
here's here's better idea just you know
this is something I was considering for
my own daughter's just born rather than
giving the child a name or a discernible
name you give them a name what you do is
you just you just you you you give them
an assortment of sounds right and then
once as they grow older they can decide
how to arrange those sounds according to
their own self-identity so the name is
something like you know free all who's
me Koff red and then or whatever it
doesn't matter and then and then as they
grow older they can take those sounds
and sort of put them in whatever order
they want maybe on a day-to-day basis
just on how they're feeling
which really lets them express
themselves okay that's just an idea back
to the debate for me the headline is
that the Dems are screwed this is a very
very weak field and their front-runner
can barely string together a coherent
sentence all of their frontrunners are
ancient and in it that was really
highlighted last night when you watch
because they had the they had Warren
Biden and Sanders in the middle of stage
and then all the irrelevant ones out on
the fringes and you just saw how old
these people are and you thought this
really is this is the best you could do
there you couldn't find anyone outside
of the nursing home to be to be your
frontrunner and you've got you know
Biden who's basically losing it the
other is a communist with a bad heart
and the other is someone a communist who
just who just who just copies all of our
talking points from the other communists
I'm not kidding about Biden not being
able to string together a coherent
sentence listen to this yeah we have to
start rewarding work not just wealth I
would eliminate the capital gains tax
that in our word I would raise the
capital gains tax to the highest rate of
39.5%
I would double it because guess what why
in god's name should someone who's
clipping coupons in the stock market
make in fact pay a lower tax rate than
someone who in fact is like I said a
schoolteacher and a firefighter it's
ridiculous and they pay a lower tax
secondly the idea that we in fact engage
in this notion that there are one point
there's one trillion six hundred forty
billion dollars in tax loopholes you
can't justify a minimum six hundred
billion dollars of that we can eliminate
it all I could go into detail hat at a
time secondly the three thirdly what we
need to do is we need to go out and make
it clear to the American people that we
are going to we are going to raise taxes
on the wealthy we're going to reduce tax
burdens on those who are not and this is
one of the reasons why these debates are
kind of crazy because everybody tries to
squeeze everything into every answer
that is given the fact is everybody's
right about the fact that the forth and
dust revolution is costing jobs it is
the fact is also corporate greed if
they're going back and not invested in
employees they're reinvesting and buying
back their stock okay look okay so he
says quoting I would eliminate the
capital gains tax I would raise the
capital gains tax because guess what why
should someone who is clipping coupons
in the stock market make in fact pay no
hado sec sorry let me let me start up
because I'm trying to maybe there's a
way to make sense of this I just I I'm
not maybe I'm just not getting it I'm
not a very smart person maybe that's
what it is okay let's try this again I
would eliminate the capital gains tax I
would raise the capital gains tax
because guess what why should someone
who is clipping coupons in the stock
market make in fact pay a lower tax rate
than someone who is in fact like I said
a schoolteacher and a firefighter I
don't know I don't know what that means
I done I'm not even trying to be you
know difficult here I just I don't know
what he's trying to say there are are we
raising or a limiting are we raising it
then eliminating it or eliminating it
than raising it and whose it they so
they're making or peg they could make
the tax or pay it and who's clipping
coupons in the stock market is that even
a thing you get that sheet of coupons a
50 50 cents off toilet paper buy one get
one free box of fruit snacks and a
coupon for the stock market this is a
this is disastrous for the Democrats
that that guy is your front runner that
guy's the best you could do and say what
you want about Donald Trump but the guy
has a lot of energy I'm not sure that
Trump is the best at stringing together
coherent sentence either which which
kind of makes me look forward to the
prospect of a debate between Biden and
Trump that would at least be
entertaining so in a sense I'm rooting
for that because can you imagine a
three-hour debate between Trump and
Biden I think at the end of it none of
us are gonna have any idea what anybody
said we'll have no clue but it'll be a
lot of fun it'll be a great deal be a
fun journey in the very least meanwhile
you've got Beto talking about
consequences for people who don't give
him their guns watch this just to follow
up your expectations aside your website
says you will find people who don't give
up their weapons that doesn't take those
weapons off the streets so to be clear
exactly how are you going to take away
weapons from people who do not want to
give them up and you don't know where
they are if someone does not turn in an
ar-15 or an ak-47 one of these weapons
of war or brings out in public and
brandis's it in an attempt to intimidate
as we saw when we were at Kent State
recently then that weapon will be taken
from them if they persist there will be
other consequences from law enforcement
but the expectation is that Americans
will follow the law I believe in this
country I believe in my fellow Americans
I believe that they will do the right
thank you mister this is the kind of
talk that excites leftists on Twitter
but it's not going to help a Democrat
beat Trump in Pennsylvania or Michigan
or Florida you know same can be said
about demonizing the wealthy which which
was another funny thing where you had
this competition on the stage between
people you know who could hate the
wealthy the most even though they're all
wealthy by the way everybody up on the
stage all of them are wealthy but
they're having this competition about
who could who could hate the wealthy the
most and notice something about Sanders
maybe you've noticed this interesting
somewhat subtle change in his rhetoric
now you may remember back in 2016 he was
constantly going on and on about
millionaires and billionaires remember
that well it's it's fascinating that
this time around he's shortened that a
little bit and now he focuses on
billionaires he doesn't really say
millionaires and billionaires anymore
they're not the bad guys it's
billionaires now that could be just
abbreviation it's too much trouble to
say millionaires and billionaires
or it could be that he himself has
become a millionaire in the mean time
and so he realized that oh maybe
millionaires aren't so bad he finally
became a millionaire and said oh you
know what this is actually great I can
see why people like it so much but those
billionaires now they're yeah they're
the problem but it was funny that
they're all competing over who can hate
the billionaires the most meanwhile you
had this guy Tom Styer I don't know who
he is no one's heard of him but he got
up on on the stage somehow and he's a
candidate now I had a great time I'll
say that much for him but he is a
billionaire and so they're going through
and each person is saying uh
billionaires are terrible billionaires
or scumbags billionaires should be
skinned alive and roasted over and
opened fire and then they go over to Tom
Steyer the billionaire sweating
profusely saying yes I agree
billionaires are I agree billionaires
are scumbags i billionaires should be
thrown into the sea in fact right after
this debate I'm gonna go throw myself
into the sea that's that's how I feel
about it but this kind of rhetoric as I
said you know it may be popular for for
among among far leftist whether we're
demonizing the wealthy screaming about
climate change advocating abortion
through all three trimesters but it's
it's it's not gonna do much for people
who are not on the far left and the
Democrats they're gonna need to win more
than just far leftist there aren't
enough of them it's the same thing I
always say about Trump that he need that
he's got his hardcore band of supporters
a pretty sizable collection of people
but it's there's not enough of them to
put him over the top and the same on the
left there are unfortunately sadly a
there's a sizable number of people who
go for this kind of stuff which is a sad
statement about our culture but there
aren't enough of them to put democrats
over the stock top speaking of abortion
the candidates on that stage they were
they were just itching to talk about
abortion they kept bringing it up when
it wasn't even the topic at hand and
eventually the the moderators had to say
okay guys calm down we're gonna talk
about killing babies we know you we know
you all love that we're gonna talk about
it or words to that effect basically and
then and then they got around to talking
about it
and when the time came of course they
all went on and on about reproductive
rights rights a term that as I have
explained many times is a total misnomer
reproductive rights is a term that means
nothing or at the very least if it means
anything it certainly has nothing to do
with abortion because abortion happens
after reproduction has already occurred
in order for there to be an abortion
something has to have already been
produced so the the human being has
already been reproduced it's not it's
not a matter of reproduction anymore
you're not controlling your reproduction
when you get an abortion you have
already produced the human being which
is now in your womb the question is is
it okay to kill inexistent human being
in the womb I would say no if you say
yes you need to be able to defend that
position explain it without recourse to
reproductive rights because reproductive
rights are irrelevant
you know what reproductive rights okay
that's that's like the the you know a
two-child policy in China or something
like that that is a government telling
people you can't reproduce more than X
amount that is a reproductive rights
issue because it's the government
literally trying to control reproduction
but no one is saying that in this
country nobody is saying women can't
reproduce nobody's saying you have to
reproduce all we're
sang as pro-lifers is that once you've
already done it
even if you didn't mean to you did now
we've got a human being on our hands and
it's not okay to kill him very simple
the only one who wasn't completely
stoked about abortion was Tulsi Gabbard
Gabbard is is still pro-abortion but at
least she supports some restrictions and
she wants there to be fewer abortions
which used to be the mainstream
Democratic position and it was for many
years safe legal and rare I believe
Tulsi Gabbard even used that phrase and
it was sort of it was sort of shocking
for some Democrats to hear it because
it'd been so long but for decades that
was the that was the slogan on the
banner that they were marching under
safe legal and rare we want abortion to
be safe legal and rare but the Democrats
now the left they don't want that
yeah safe they want even though a safe
abortion speaking of misnomers safe
abortion is a contradiction in terms
because all there's always at least one
person killed in an abortion so I could
we couldn't call it safe say they wanted
to be safe they certainly want it to be
legal but rare no they want more
abortions and in fact Leanna when is the
she was the former CEO of Planned
Parenthood her reign was cut very short
she was she was fired basically and I
think now we know why because she came
out on Twitter last night after the
debate and agreed with Tulsi Gabbard and
said yeah we should abortion should be
legal women should be able to do it but
but but we should try to cut down on the
number of abortions and it's very fat in
fact I would recommend if you're on
Twitter go to Leanna winds Twitter page
look at that comment by her mainly to
see the to see the comments underneath
it from all these leftist saying
basically accusing her of being a
traitor saying no we don't want rare
abortions we don't want there to be
fewer aboard so we like abortions we
want there to be more of them and keep
that in mind the next time
because anytime you refuse to use the
word the euphemism pro-choice and
instead you say pro-abortion
what are you always here you always here
oh we're not pro-abortion no one's
pro-abortion that's crazy well if you
don't want abortions to be rare if you
have a problem with that goal then you
are definitely pro-abortion and speaking
of tulsi gabbard the last thing i'll say
about the debate is watching this now i
you know i'm no tulsi gabbard fan she's
still at the end of the day a leftist
but i think she would easily be the
strongest competitor against donald
trump because she's not a crazy far-left
leftist she she would win the the
anti-trump vote as any democrat will and
that's what they're all relying on is
that there's got to be a strong
anti-trump vote and anyone who's not
Trump will win that vote she'll win some
people in the middle because of her
positions on things like gun rights and
abortion and so on it's a little bit
more in step with the with the you know
with what people in the middle think she
probably even win some conservatives I
think she'd be a formidable challenge I
think she could probably even win in a
landslide and on top of that she's young
and attractive and and had a veteran I
mean all those things help but she has
no chance she has absolutely no chance
because she's not gonna get through a
primary she's polling at 2% leftist are
not interested in someone who has sane
and reasonable positions they aren't
interested in it and they're gonna pay
the price for that maybe in the form of
another four years for Donald Trump
alright let's let's move on Gina red
Rodriguez is an actress apparently she
got into some hot water yesterday
because she recorded an Instagram video
of herself rapping along to I think it
was a Fugees song from the 90s and the
song contains the n-word as many rap
songs do
she's saying the n-word in the song
because it was in a song and this became
a huge outrage people are very upset
Gina Rodriguez got cancelled immediately
cancelled from what I'm not sure I don't
know what she does or who she is or why
she's famous
she almost immediately came out with a
with an apology video you know begging
for forgiveness and like I said I don't
know who she is it doesn't matter though
because unless this person is literally
in the Klan which is unlikely for
someone in Gina Rodriguez I don't need
to know their background to say that
this controversy is completely stupid
the idea that it's racist to sing the
lyrics to a popular song that's been on
the radio for like 20 years is just
beyond the bounds of stupidity it it
goes beyond stupidity
you know pure stupidity it leaves the
atmosphere and achieves intergalactic
levels of stupidity and this is very
obvious there's just no way around this
logic if the word is so bad that it's
racist simply to sing along to a song
that contains it then the word should
not be in the song to begin with the
idea that there could be song lyrics
that you're only allowed to sing if you
have the right skin pigmentation is
again very very stupid and I'm gonna
keep going back to that word stupid
because that's what this is again if
this word has that kind of power if it
is that incomprehensible evil that to
even utter its syllables
no matter the context is an unforgivable
sin then nobody should be saying it and
certainly nobody should be putting it in
a pop song that goes on the radio that
this to me seems very reasonable or on
the other hand we could go this way we
could say context matters if
using a racial slur as a racial slur
well then that's obviously racist and
terrible and if Gina Rodriguez was on
video shouting racial slurs in a racist
context I would say she brought the
consequences on herself but if the
context is you singing the lyrics to a
song or matter-of-factly quoting someone
or reading something that has the word
in it then clearly it is not racist
because there's no intent a statement
can only be racist if it has a racist
intent behind it that's how human
communication works it's it's not you
know there is no word that's like some
sort of magical spell that if you even
say the word you you turn into it's like
a magical spell that turns you into a
frog or something well this is not a
magical spell that turns you into a
racist because you said the word in any
context whatsoever and besides the other
thing it doesn't make any sense about
this is when you're quoting someone or
singing a song or whatever and and you
censor yourself and you say and you say
instead n-word you're still causing your
listeners to think that word in their
heads I think bill burr has a bit about
this or maybe Luisa can't remember which
one but the point is you're still
communicating the word right you're just
communicating without all the syllables
so so is there something mystical about
that particular arrangement of syllables
that makes you racist if you utter it
without the right skin pigmentation
regardless of content or or of context
it starts to sound superstitious after a
while and it
just doesn't make any sense I have no
you know I have no dog in the fight with
Gina Rodriguez like I said I don't even
know who she is and yeah was it stupid
for her to I don't even know why you
would take an Instagram video of
yourself singing along to a song on the
radio and then put it I don't even know
why you would do that
so it's stupid for a number of reasons
but it's in a song you sang the words of
a song and if this all ends with people
saying hey you know maybe we should put
fewer profanities and slurs and
everything in songs to begin with I
would say great yeah that sounds good
but if you're gonna put it in the song
you can't get mad at people for singing
along to it all right finally I can't
believe I'm gonna do this but I want to
play something from Keeping Up with the
Kardashians actually it's worse than
that because I'm gonna play it's a
report on Entertainment Tonight about
Keeping Up with the Kardashians and by
the way I'm not trying to be funny here
I had no idea that Keeping Up with the
Kardashians was still on the air I
thought it went off the air like 10
years ago I really had no idea that it
still did it what did they reboot reboot
it or something or has it been on TV
this whole time I don't know because
aren't all these people billionaires now
and they're still doing a reality show
so um apparently it's still on the air
and there's a certain scene that people
are talking about some people are upset
upset at Kanye West because he confessed
to his wife Kim Kardashian that he's not
comfortable with her wearing skimpy
outfits watch this you're on your
transformation doesn't mean that I'm in
the right I'm in the same spot with you
okay all right cool
Kanye West storms out on Kim Kardashian
after confronting her about her super
sexy Met Gala look I'm really freaking
out on Sunday night's episode of Keeping
Up with the Kardashians
Kanye surprisingly admits to having an
issue with people gawking at his
gorgeous white horses like underwear is
high and say that you're not into a
corset back I mean we love each other's
opinions well maybe not in this case as
Kim was not okay with the 42 year old
rappers concerns over her choice in
wardrobe for fashions biggest night just
went through this transition where from
being a rapper like looking at all these
girls and looking at my wife like oh my
girl needs to be just like the other
girls showing a body off show initial
and that and I didn't realize that that
was affecting like my soul and my spirit
as someone that's married and loved and
the father of like now would have about
to be four kids
Kim shut that down real quick you've
built me up to have be this like sexy
person and confidence
and all this stuff just because you're
on a journey and you're on your
transformation doesn't mean that I'm in
the right I'm in the same spot with you
Entertainment Tonight tells us this is
surprising it's surprising that Kanye
West doesn't want his wife running
around like that and a lot of people
online have echoed this sentiment it's
surprising that a man you know a husband
doesn't want other men AAG lling his
wife it's surprising that a father
doesn't want that sort of example set
for his daughters no that's not
surprising that's that's normal that's
that's that's healthy but I kind of love
that clip that I just played because you
see this stark contrast between the very
thoughtful honest explanation from Kanye
about why he cherishes his wife's
dignity and why he as a father and a
husband wants her to respect herself and
show more modesty and he's sharing that
and then the Entertainment Tonight lady
cuts in and says Kim shuts that down
real quick it's just so vapid and
shallow where you see is a perfect
illustration of how the other side you
know you've got the well I guess we call
now traditional values which now Kanye
West of all people is exhibiting and
good for him you see how the other side
is is so vapid and shallow and I'm just
gonna say this if you don't if you
really don't understand where Kanye is
coming from in that clip if you don't
understand what he's saying or why he's
saying it if you if you really do find
it shocking scandalizing then I would
say don't get married because you're not
marriage material
you're never gonna have a successful
marriage and I'm not saying that you
have to agree 100% with everything that
Kanye West is saying there in order to
be you know to have a good healthy
marriage but you should at least
understand what he's saying
this this
instinct that espouse fields not wanting
his wife to go out half-naked and be
awed by other men that is a natural
healthy instinct and if you can't even
understand that if the idea of having a
truly monogamous exclusive relationship
where you both have some dignity and
some modesty and there are certain
things physically emotionally that you
keep between yourselves and you don't
share with the world if you if you don't
understand that that again I just you
your your marriage probably isn't gonna
work out for you because that's what
marriage is all about it's all about
having those exclusive intimate things
that aren't shared with everybody else
now because you're not sharing every
aspect of your spouse with the entire
world and when you get married as a
spouse what you're saying to the person
you're marrying is there are parts of me
you know metaphorically and literally
that will not that are not going to be
shared with anyone else
it's just between you and me so that's
it really is it's like something out of
it II ah cracy which i think is one of
the most prophetic movies to come out in
the last twenty or thirty years but this
is like something straight out of a
theocracy people are gawking laughing
like hyenas because a man you know
doesn't want his wife going out in
public basically nude alright um so
kanye west who ever thought Kanye West
would become the spokesman for Christian
modesty but this is where we are in 2019
it's great thanks everybody for watching
thanks for listening Godspeed
Matt Walsh show is produced by Robert
Sterling associate producer alexia
Garcia Del Rio executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer his Austin
Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena Matt
Walsh show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 if you prefer
facts over feelings aren't offended by
the brutal truth and you can still laugh
at the insanity filling our national
news cycle well tune in to the Ben
Shapiro show we'll get a whole lot of
that and much more see you there